I'm Alanna fish I'm an assistant
professor at the University of Alberta
and I'm also a Canada Safari i J
my research is trying to find
connections between the way computers
understand the world and the way we
understand the world so when we build
computer models of for example computer
vision we ask computers to tell us
what's in a picture and it turns out the
way they learn to do that actually looks
a lot like the way the human brain does
it so I'm my research is trying to draw
those connections between the way the
brain works and the way that machine
learning models work we understood how
people perceived images we could build
computer models that perceive images in
the same way and that might mean they're
better at that perception it could also
mean things like when they make a
mistake it's a more human mistake and
that sort of thing could be really
important for applications where
computers are interacting with the real
world I think Canada has been so well
positioned for the AI revolution I think
we happen to have a really strong group
of people already here and then with the
funding from Seifer on the Canadian
government were able to grow that team
in a way that has really put us ahead of
other countries I think it's a great
time to be in Canada for AI but the
thing that I think has been most
important to me with my involvement with
see far has been the networking and the
getting to know other people who are
working on AI so that has been has had a
huge impact on my career a measurable
impact on my career already and I'm
quite a new researcher so having those
sorts of opportunities early on is
really important you can never really
tell what what new science is going to
change the world and so finding the
right people smart people and giving
them the money they need to make
progress is really important and it's
what will make science into reality
you